hello everyone and welcome back to the
20/20 candidates tournament or not as
many of you have probably heard already
at the feeder candidates tournament has
been canceled well not really canceled
but more more of an adjournment it will
be continued at a better day so for now
they are postponing it and here is the
official statement from feeding so let's
just check that out before we check out
to this game from round seven so the
official statement from feed a web site
today the government of the Russian
Federation announced that starting March
27 2020 Russia interrupts air traffic
with other countries without indicating
any time frames via can a fee they
cannot continue the tournament without
guarantees for the players and officials
safe and timely return home in this
situation and on the basis of Clause 1.5
rules of candidates tournament the
feeder president decided to stop the
tournament it will be continued later
with the exact dates to be announced as
soon as the global situation related to
the code 19 pandemic will allow as it
was stipulated by the special rules
agreed with the players before the start
of the event the results of the seven
rounds played remain valid and the
tournament will be resumed in the same
composition starting with the games of
the eighth round fides grateful to the
players officials volunteers and the
entire team of organizers including the
Chess Federation of Russia and the main
partner of the tournament Cemal and
sincerely Arkady dvorkovich field
president so there we have it that's
basically it it's really it so it's a
shame for for Tim or a job over because
basically he asked for determined to be
postponed a fee they said no they gave
the spot the maxime beaugeois growling
the tournament and now the tournament is
forcefully postponed and it's it's just
terrible
I mean however they play this out it's
it's always gonna be what what if this
happened what would this happen what if
what if for a job of maybe played and
then he won and now we have Maxie Murphy
logger leading determine what if he wins
did he actually win it because well it's
just a whole lot of mess but that's for
someone else to worry about we are here
to check out the games from round seven
and here it is ding opens with d4
and we do have a nice photo of the two
of them so let's just check it out there
we have it
I think again with his little blue chair
Alex ankle with the with the well normal
green one so let's check it out
now we have Knight to f6 ding replies
with c4 and e6 and here I think it
doesn't feel like we're going for the
names over here or maybe maybe even a
BOGO Indian or or maybe summer goes and
stuff
so instead g3 he prepared he goes for
the Catalan and ok Bishop to b4 would
check Bishop to d2 and now Bishop back
to e7 that White's Bishop is awkwardly
placed on d2 Bishop to g2 ending out d5
the usual move with Knight to f3 and
both players just Castle with castles
castles Knight B to d7 and Queen to c2
so the continuing development we have c6
strengthening in the center and now
Bishop to f4 getting the best sharper to
a more useful square we have b6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and now rook to d1 as the bishop
is coming the wealth to this diagonal so
the rook will be useful there also
you're lying aligning it with the Queen
Bishop still to a6 threatening to
capture the pawn here and Knight B to d2
defending the c4 pawn rook the c8
developing and now rook a to c1 also
developing and now Knight to h5 are
going after dings Bishop on f4 dingos
back Bishop to e3 and Alex and repeats
saying if you want to go back I'm just
gonna repeat and there is one game where
where such a repetition happened but
then White's deviated I was in 2017 a
college month versus a female could that
ended in a draw but here ding right away
goes for Bishop to g5 and it is a new
move in the position so already as a
move 14 we have a completely new game so
best of the back to be seven now and
Knights the e5
by dink here we have a series of trades
Knight captures on e5 d captures now
comes Knight to g4 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Knight to f3 guarding
the e5 pawn and Alexandre says ok that
time for that point to go he goes f6
we eat captures and Knight captures and
now
well you could go for some 95 and F for
ideas
ding decides to go with Bishop to h3
instead putting pressure on this well
for the moment weak pawn here and you
cannot advance it because the rook would
hang on c8
so first rook CT 8 and now while
preparing for e for this 'if I've idea
dingos Queen to a for saying that okay
I'm interested in grabbing your a
7-point what do you play here and Alex &
Co plays the absolute best c5 and here
you really have to ask yourselves do you
capture an a7 or maybe not what's what's
preventing me from capturing this point
is it a free pawn is it is are these two
pawns free what's going on here now to
answer this question we would have to
probably make a separate video because
capturing on a7 is so complicated it's
uh it would certainly be a job for
someone like the magician of Riga but I
will just show one of the lines as it's
just crazy for example if you capture
the pawn queen to c7 now just
threatening a rook to e8 which would
pick up the Queen and here white goes
Knight to d4 and now it looks a bit
crazy but point is that if the knight is
captured then you can have captures here
you open up an attack towards the Queen
Queen e7 now you advance the pawn you
want to get the Queen away from the
defense of the bishop you again move the
Queen and now let's say rook the c7 and
the blacks position will will just be
extremely difficult to play you are
regaining your piece back and it's just
it's just bad so what you would have to
do after Queen to see 794 you would have
to go for rook to e8 stick with your
plan
but now Knight captures on e6 attacking
the black Queen the black Queen moves
and now you have C captures on d5 we
have Knight captures on d5 and now Queen
captures on b7 really really insane
stuff a Queen captures on b7 now Knight
captures on f8 King captures an f8 and
now Bishop the g2 now preparing to win
the night also and it's not it's
impossible to defend it because after
rook you're just gonna go rook to D to
double up here and you're
win denied whatever black plays rook CD
one let's say g5 and you will now pick
up the night Bishop captures and after
the Queen moves and now you're gonna
just fortify the position would be four
and it's a really really we well a good
position for both players because you
have a bishop and rook for a queen plus
your up two points and it should be
playable for both sides that really
complicated stuff you don't you don't
have to worry about ideas like h4
because even if captures captures it's
not a problem you always have the light
square bishop the guard is diagonal so
it would be really crazy but this is
just one of the lines that can happen
after Queen captures here so like I said
this would be definitely a job for the
magician of Riga
so ding first prepares that would be for
simply saying that okay now if you
capture it then I capture and then I
have the C file for my rook ready which
is what happens in the game alexengel
has to decide whether he wants to
advance the d4 or he wants to accept
dings challenge and he accepted the
challenge Queen captures here now the
pawn is guarded but now Queen captures
on a 7 and now Queen the c7 will be met
with pawn captures here and then just
kicking the Queen away from c7 similar
to the line we've shown so Knights the
e4 instead now going for Knight to the
c32 e2 and now dingos Queen captures and
b6 we have Knight to c3 now going after
this check while the rookies under
attack rook to e1 and now D captures and
C for creating the these two very
advanced at pawns and also you are you
are pressuring the night here so for
example Knight captures with Czech
removes the defender of the night you
pick up the night good good things can
happen here and ding-ding I can't really
allow these two to remain like this he
plays a3 he wants the well either create
some weaknesses or of course you cannot
capture because the knight hangs so here
you might go for Knight captures an e2
but again it's a really crazy line for
example if Knight characters on e2 then
rook captures Bishop captures an f3 rook
captures on e6 and now Queen to g5 with
an attack on the rook rook captures on
c4 and now rook to b8 you take away the
Queen put a look behind your passport
quinta III you trade Queens captures
captures and now b3 a link Cinco would
be down upon but he has this incredibly
passed a beep on so here Dean would have
to go for go for the pawn rook rook to C
1 B 2 and now well probably Bishop to e6
with checking to h8 and rook to be one
stop the pawn and it would be a better
position for Alex and regardless of
being being up upon because this point
can't survive for very long and it's
it's just better for Alex and go where
he would be able to do something about
it that's well that that would have been
for him him to show but okay after a
three Alex and go first decides for
Bishop to b5 he strengthens the c4 pawn
and now only after Queen captures on
before we have Queen Catherine before it
captures in the now nightcap for Sonny
to with check rook captures and now not
Bishop captures because if Bishop
captures then you allow bushel captures
on e6 with check and after King to h8
now you pick up well the first rookie 3
you kick away the bishop and then you
will be able to pick up this bone so of
course this would be much better for
Davis so instead Luke captures on f3 and
now Bishop to g2 we have looked back to
f8 and now rook to d2 threatening to
pick up the bishop here and here Alex
anko has to decide whether he wants to
keep the pressure or he wants to trade
everything with rook to b8 so here ding
decided to Alex and Co decided for rook
to b8 he goes after this pawn and now
Dean just trades with Bishop captures
pawn captures rook captures and rook
captures and before and now rook the c2
not allowing the passport across the
second-ranked we have worked the c8 Alex
anko also puts a look behind the passed
pawn and now King f1 being started to
bring in the key into the game we have
c3 King to e2 and now rook the b7 asking
ding what do you what do you play here
rook to d3 he goes after the pawn here
but now rook the b2 saying that okay now
if you capture obviously I'm just
winning because of rogue characters I'm
up a whole rook
so after King to d1 defending the rook
alexengel goes to rugby 1 check we have
kingi to look to be 2 again offering the
same idea king
one and after work to be one check it
was in this position unmoved 40 after
reaching time control that the players
agreed to a draw as there's no there's
no way to continue pushing here it's
equal material and although Alexandro
has an advanced past pawn other two
rooks are making it impossible for him
if rook h1 you just play h4 and then
you're not in time to get back you will
lose your c3 pawn and if you try
something else
let's say rook the b3 just keep the game
going then wife can completely cut you
off with rook to d7 year or King is not
getting any more active and if rogue b2
now King d3 now you could go rook the f8
you go after the pawn f4 if g5 would
just trade everything captures on c3
you're gonna go captures here captures
here and rook captures on h2 and we we
end up in this position where you can
defend either with the rooks or maybe
King before just defend the pawn and
it's a completely equal material and
it's justifiable that the game ended in
a draw after look to b1 check on move 40
so really crazy game like I said there
was this maybe option of Queen captures
on a7 for ding but it's impossible to
calculate what happens after Queen
captures an a7 he would just burn
incredible amounts of time and probably
mess up somewhere and there was this 1.4
for Alex anko after a 3 he could have
gone for this Knight captures an e2
which would definitely give him
advantage but both of them were
reluctant to act on it and of course
Indian it ended in a draw so that's the
last game will be showing from the
candidates tournament in quite a while
until the situation in the world picks
up and we can continue with the
candidates tournament with the same
setup of course but that you know we are
continuing as usual we are continuing to
Paul Morphy saga maybe maybe maybe we
can throw a tournament or two or a
stream or two if you guys are interested
let me know in the comments and also
yeah well what's your opinion on this
whole thing regarding the postponement
of defeated candidates tournament and
done this whole well now situation that
basically everything happened the way
her job wanted it to happen but it just
happened without him because Vita was
reluctant to immediately postponed
and really I don't know it's it's a
really tough spot for feet is to be in
but yeah the that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank a
lot of Roger Billings Lucian Cardona no
David Kaiser anti crazy witch and Isaac
Garcon for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video serum tinkle for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga checking up on you wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever
whatever else happens in the world of
chess so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an external rest of your
day